what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with actually
what I think is one of the coolest
stories in DC we were so far with Batman
which is called the gift and this
actually sees the return of Booster Gold
now Booster Gold also did appear in the
booster shot with Superman but we
haven't really covered that yet that
actually comes in the aftermath of the
Oz effect so I will probably cover that
sometime in the next couple weeks or so
but when it comes to like this that this
is really I think this does a better job
of kind of hitting home at the nature of
Booster Gold really feel like a lot of
new fans and the reason why is because
for people who are getting into DC
rebirth' are really getting into DC
Comics because of DC rebirth there's a
very good chance and you have no idea
who Booster Gold is now he was in like
new 52 and he did see him there but
really a lot of fans Mondelez how they
think of Booster Gold really comes from
like before the new 52 right like it
comes with a post-crisis landscape and
the reason why was because that was when
Booster Gold really blew out Booster
Gold was introduced in 1986 so he's a
post-crisis character but the idea here
is that when DC when you had the
original Justice League back in breda
back in out braving the bold and then
they got their own solo series you know
really for my 1960 going forward when
crisis on Infinite Earths happened
DC canceled the Justice League in its
entirety they got rid of the traditional
Justice League team Batman Superman
Wonder Woman Green Lantern all that kind
of good stuff the flash and they
relaunched it under Keith Giffen and JM
DeMatteis as Justice League
International and the reason for this
was because by the time crisis on
Infinite Earths happen the core members
of the Justice League were hugely
popular I mean they didn't really need a
Justice League team it was cool to have
but the concept of the team could be
used for other purposes namely
bolstering the popularity of characters
who just really couldn't sell their own
books because the name Justice League
was so huge and so handing it over to to
given and Mateus and then having them
revamp it as Justice League
International meant the name remain the
same but the roster changed now of
course in order to keep weary readers
from walking away in its entirety
they threw Batman on his leader of the
team and that was enough to keep people
you know keep people interested and then
once you know the the roster began to
take form and you had like Guy Gardner
and he had Booster Gold and he had Blue
Beetle the kind of comedy slash serious
nature of the stories proved to be
hugely popular Justice League
International was massive when it first
showed up people loved it now as time
progressed it began like people began to
lose interest and that's the reason why
in 1998 uh Jess
the International was just basically
wiped away all the Justice League teams
were removed in their entirety and then
you got JLA by Grant Morrison Justice
League of America it was the return of
the original Justice League team but
nonetheless when it came to the
character of Booster Gold he was really
popular because one he was a glory hound
and two like he was basically a crook he
was he was a guy from the future who
would use his knowledge of of current
events because he was from the future
and showed up and then was just like I
know how to save everything and it was
funny for what it was but it was really
more the relationship between Blue
Beetle and and Ted Kord that helped to
make Booster Gold hugely popular like
that's really really what kind of set
things off this sort of like you know
buddy cot duo that the two of them
formed made them wildly popular for a
lot of fans and so really liked that
aspect of Blue Beetle always almost
always remain there were a lot of great
stories that dealt with the idea that he
felt like he had the weight of the world
on his shoulders but for the most part
he was just kind of like that comedic
element and so he always had that that
little bit of humor here so what this
story does is it initially does not pick
up with Booster Gold
instead it picks up with Green Lantern
it picks up with Hal Jordan and he
basically offs himself which is actually
kind of wild because it's like like
right off the bat I mean one he's kind
of grinning and looks pretty sadistic
and screwed up but two he's just kind of
like look the Rings don't let you take
and take yourself out but if you
overcome the willpower of the ring like
you can do whatever you want to do and
like that falls in line like we know
that from the Green Lantern mythos now
of course we end up finding out he does
this in the face of Booster Gold but
this is kind of crazy because everything
is screwed up right now and it's kind of
wild because it's like what in the world
is going on and so ultimately you end up
having Blue Beetle who's just kind of
like okay look you know we got to go
find Batman you know we gotta go find
Batman and we have to show um you know
everything that's going on what have you
and then of course he's taken out from
behind by Batman but Batman's Batman's
wearing guns and so right off the bat
the idea that Batman's strapped with
like massive bullets he's got grenades
he's got you know these huge guns he
looks like Arnold Schwarzenegger from
Terminator blended with cable for Marvel
Comics which is actually pretty cool he
looks like The Punisher can we all just
admit here that if Batman became The
Punisher it would probably be the
coolest thing ever like that's a story
we need to have but basically it's this
idea that is almost reminiscent a
flashpoint when you have the flashpoint
event anyway we got this alternate
reality we had a circumstance where
Bruce Wayne died instead of his parents
and Thomas Wayne became Batman and
Martha Wayne became the Joker there's an
amazing story when it came out it was
like what is a a - maybe there's like a
three or four part story I think was for
but with this thing it's cool because
this version of Batman is just like
ruthless and it's very reminiscent of
how Thomas Wayne was Thomas Wayne was
cut through he would kill people he
would do whatever he had to do but while
you end up having like Booster Gold and
Batman who were facing off against one
another we transition over to Jason Todd
and what we end up finding out here is
Jason Todd is not the Red Hood instead
what's been going on here is Jason Todd
is actually like he owns a tire company
and this tire company specializes in
basically creating tires that shock
Joker's from stealing people's stealing
people's rims basically now again this
is cool because this is blending a lot
of small things together right like I
mean if you if you look at DC like have
you been reading DC for a while then
like it's taking all these little
threads all these little tidbits and
sort of bringing them all together for
example the concept of the Joker's that
probably comes from Batman Beyond and
Batman Beyond the Joker had long since
been dead and in his place came like the
Joker gang and so you had like all these
people men and women who would dress up
as Joker's and then go out and commit
crimes also notice here that is
basically Joker with like a rod in his
hand which is kind of like a throwback
basically to like the the death death on
the family story arc where Jason Todd
originally died in DC Comics but this is
kind of cool because what this indicates
here is that of course Jason Todd never
became Red Hood which indicates that
Jason Todd was never adopted by Batman
if that wasn't the case then we don't
really know where he ends up coming from
instead we just know he kind of becomes
a tire mechanic the other half of this
is Booster Gold talking to his machine
Skeets now Skeets is the means by which
Booster Gold travels back and forth
through time and will actually get a
little bit of clarification on that here
in a minute so we won't spoil it for
right here and now but the thing that I
want you guys to notice here it's really
the relationship between the two of them
because this was a hallmark of Booster
Gold the fact that he and his machine
would bicker with each other
Booster Gold was always a character who
seemed kind of childish and when taken
out of context and and really when when
sort of just thrown out there by himself
it can be hit and miss in a lot of ways
he can be like Deadpool I think the
success of Booster Gold really comes
into play when someone takes his
character and they throw it into a comic
where he has someone to bounce off of
and that's why Booster Gold will always
worked so well because in a lot of ways
the relationship between like Booster
Gold and and Blue Beetle
or like Booster Gold and Batman or even
Superman is very much akin to like cable
and Deadpool they just kind of bounce
off each other it's serious combined
with like humor now Brewster Gold's
taken by Batman kind of whisked away and
it's kind of like hung from from a
balcony and that's when you end up
finding out this Batman is actually Dick
Grayson now again this is
one of the things that I love about
stories like this is because we're not
gonna find out how Dick Grayson became
Batman and that's why things like this
are so cool why the mini series of like
like white knight and and things like
night wings new order the reason why
those little things and tidbits like
this are so cool is because they keep us
wanting more and that's actually a
genius move to kind of sidetrack here
for a second one of the big issues that
Marvel has been struggling with for the
last while is they've really kind of
reverted back to where DC used to be
maybe 50 or 60 years ago in the sense of
they're like very very linear stories
and Marvel is like that when Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby were writing stories but
they're very linear stories it's just
kind of like you know here's an event
that sets off this story and then here's
a story happening and then the story
ends done and like that's it it doesn't
really give you any reason to want
anything more than what you already see
but with stories like this the reason
why these are a great reprieve is
because you're just kind of like well
then how in the hell did Digg race and
become Batman
where's Bruce Wayne like what's going on
with Bruce Wayne's character like those
are the kind of things that you want to
know and they keep us coming back and
they keep us wanting more and then we
end up tweeting the hell out of the
writer give us the answer to this
question give us a one shot man like do
something that's where we could we kind
of get a real cool interest with those
things now again the other thing to bear
in mind here is that when Booster Gold
makes his escape one thing to remember
is that while he is a glory hog and
while he is somewhat nonsensical he is
not incapable Booster Gold is very much
a capable superhero in a wide variety of
different ways what we also end up doing
here and this is really more of a of an
aside than anything else we actually
pick up with Duke Thomas and this is
kind of interesting here I think this
was really done just for the purpose of
showing where Duke is in and what Dukes
doing but he hasn't really had that many
significant roles in DC Comics that
there's a reason for fans to care about
what's going on with him here but again
it is kind of a cool thing to see I mean
at this point Duke Thomas is basically
had his head cut open he's been
lobotomized and someone's just kind of
screwed feeding him and that's it but
the fact remains here what we end up
doing is switching over to Bruce Wayne
and that's when we find out in this line
and this in this current set of
circumstances Bruce Wayne ever became
Batman and the reason why Bruce Wayne
ever became Batman is because Bruce
Wayne's parents never died Thomas and
Martha Wayne are still very much a lot
and Booster Gold
shows up and he's like hey man like I
got a present for you what I did is I
went back in time and I saved your
parents from dying and so like your
parents are alive now because of what
I've done but I did that because you're
getting married and I wanted you to see
what happiness would be like so like now
we have to go back and we have to like
let your parents died it's kind of
screwed up
it's kind of messed up like hey man this
life you're living is a lie but this is
the gift that I gave you and now I'm
gonna take this gift and take it away
it's like giving a person a million
dollars and just saying I wanted you to
see what it was like to hold a million
bucks thanks and then just take the
million dollars and leave but like
that's Booster Gold now the funny thing
about this is the responsive Bruce Wayne
is like I've always known that that was
the case I've always had this itch under
my skin there's always just like this
phrase on the edge of my tongue I knew
that something wasn't right here it was
an itch that I couldn't scratch things
are not the way they're supposed to be
and so the result is that he's like okay
I mean I guess things could go back to
normal but I don't want them to so he
destroys Skeets strapped you know Travis
Booster Gold on them in the modern day
and leaves him there and then just
leaves and goes back to his life and we
pick up a year later and then we end up
having Booster Gold who breaks into
Arkham Asylum to free Catwoman and so
picking up with with Thomas and Bruce
it's kind of cool here but we also know
finding out some somewhat seedy things
are going on of course you know Oswald
Cobblepot the penguin basically is
President of the United States but still
like Thomas has done some seedy things
and that's the interesting thing about
this is when you go through and you look
at the various iterations of Thomas
Wayne and DC Comics and even when you go
back and you look at like the origin of
Batman the indication is that Thomas
Wayne was always a good guy though along
it was because we didn't get a whole lot
about him and it's only really in like
expanded flashbacks or just to say
flashbacks would give you more
information about his dad that there
seems to be the possibility that maybe
he did some seedy things that maybe he
wasn't really as legit as we thought he
was but still like in this he's been
working to try to make Gotham a better
place but there's just kind of something
off about him but in the midst of all
this because of the fact that
everything's crashing down because
villains are going awry because
everything's going crazy here what we
end up having is one he suffers a heart
attack and to the revelation is that
like Oswald Cobblepot is gonna bring in
the forces of Ra's al Ghul who have
basically conquered Europe and Asia
combine them into a single continent and
then use those forces to essentially
quell any kind of rebel threat that
exists inside the United States but the
hidden letters here the hidden wording
the invisible ink really kind of says
that like Ra's al Ghul like once he gets
in he will not leave and so he'll get
his forces in here and then he could
potentially conquer the United States
not only that of course pick me up with
Booster Gold
he's really kind of rambling on to
Selina Kyle but we start learning some
things that are going on behind the
scenes that when Booster Gold traveled
back in time and stopped the parents of
Bruce Wayne from dying
that of course that meant Bruce Wayne
never became Batman
and because Bruce Wayne ever became
Batman Bruce Wayne never joined the
Justice League and because Bruce Wayne
never joined the Justice League that
meant that there was no one there to
save the Justice League when they first
faced off against star up and when that
happened
Starro killed two Justice League they're
all dead and so it's kind of crazy
I mean you end up having like you know
um you know Green Lantern of course he
was alive but like the the indication
seems to be here Wonder Woman presumably
Martian Manhunter the flash they're all
dead
but again this is one of those things
we're just like whoa I mean it like I
want to see him I want to see this
climactic battle and I want to see how I
want to see how they died like those are
the kind of things that are kind of
interesting because I'll be honest with
you guys if there's a story where like
the Justice League dies or like a
superhero team that I really love if
there's like this dystopian future where
everything goes bad and they die like I
want to see how it happens like I want
to know this I want to see that take
place but booster gold's idea is okay we
have to take you captain we have to get
you to Bruce Wayne because Bruce Wayne's
gonna marry you and and if we get you to
him then everything will be fixed and
everything will be fine and the two of
you will get married and so his line of
logic is I'll take you to Bruce Wayne
and everything will be sorted out and so
of course picking up with Bruce and
Martha this is actually one of those
instances when you see a harder side of
Martha you never really seek Martha was
always kind of given to us is like this
tender person of course it's kind of
funny because she puts on this hard edge
the doctor comes out and says if you'll
come with me and she's thinking what
about my husband he's like well I need
you to follow me in her immediate
responses we are Wayne's of Gotham City
we not follow anybody you tell me what I
want to know not now but right now and
it's cool because it's just like BAM
Martha Wayne just boom just like that
and I like that I like seeing that hard
gritty edge of Martha Wayne because it's
like a side you never really see and
it's kind of a way to say look like the
Wayne's are still very powerful in the
city of Gotham they're still like
probably the number one family in Gotham
City they're a very big name and so
again we end up finding out that Thomas
survived the experience he's not dead
but then from there you basically end up
picking up with like booster and in in
Catwoman traveling to the house of
really - like Wayne Manor to pick up
with with Thomas and Martha and Bruce
the problem with this is that Booster
Gold is only ever paying half attention
to what's going on and he doesn't
realize the reason why Catwoman was in
Arkham Asylum is it because she's just
like an incorrigible robber or anything
like that
it's because she's an insane serial
killer and so as soon as she gets into
Wayne Manor
she starts killing everybody Alfred is
the first one to fall which is always
the case guys riders can we please stop
killing Alfred I love Alfred all right
please stop killing
man Alfred Catwoman goes through there
and she literally just starts tearing
people up and then just starts like
taking everybody out
now of course Batman's follow them there
and what this does is it turns into like
a bloodbath I mean this is a massacre
Batman goes after Booster Gold and
Catwoman Catwoman goes after Bruce Wayne
and Ann Thomas and Martha Wayne and she
kills them all like Alfred like Catwoman
kills Alfred shoe killer kills Thomas
she kills Martha she kills Batman she
kills them all except for Booster Gold
but then you end up having Bruce Wayne
who gets the shot off on Catwoman and so
booster gold's unconscious and everyone
else is dead and it's just like Jesus
like this is insane Tom King the Tom
King knows how to write a donkey knows
that already quite crazy stuff it's if
but it's cool though because from there
you basically pick up with this this
this idea that Batman or I guess Bruce
Wayne is now completely and totally
resolved and what he's actually doing is
taking shots at Batman at taking shots
at Catwoman by various statues that he's
created and honing his skills but this
is really Tom Kane's way it seems to be
Tom Keens way of saying that like Bruce
Wayne does not have the various skills
with weapons use and things like that
that we would expect he's literally like
learning how to shoot here and it works
for what it is and the reason why is
because it fits in perfectly with the
way the stories being told that with
Bruce Wayne having never lost his
parents he never had a reason to become
Batman which meant he never had a reason
to learn all that kind of stuff and so
because he never had a reason he's
basically learning those things now and
so he's not as capable as we would
expect him to be but he's also got
Booster Gold just kind of chained up
inside this giant cave and that's really
about it he's just kind of keeping in
there and so what ends up doing is
having guys basically clean up Booster
Gold they fix Skeets and the response is
you're gonna take us back in time and
you're gonna take us back to the to the
point where my parents died and we're
gonna fix it now here's the funny thing
about this it's the time machine of
Booster Gold is not an absolute thing
you just kinda have to say like send us
back to like about this general point in
time like send us back to this point
where I did a thing like that's that's
how his time machine works I said where
Bruce Wayne kind of offers out it orally
says that's how Booster Gold puts off
the reception of this time machine works
and so we're Batman's deal where Bruce
Wayne is kind of like okay look fine
then like take us back ten minutes
before my parents died then you in turn
have Booster Gold he's like okay we can
do that now this is what this is one of
the funnier moments in the comics
because then like as that happens he
just kind of like he's like yeah he's
like he's like Skeets do that send us 10
minutes before Bruce Wayne's parents
died and then winks and so like you give
this hilarious exchange because he's
just like Bruce Wayne he's like like
what did you just wait why did you wink
and it just kinda like this going back
and forth like what do you mean like I
mean I didn't I didn't wink so I guess
you did it's like well I mean I winked
but there was a fly in my eyes like
there was no fly there like it's funny
to see these this is this going back and
forth
this is a moment when I say that Booster
Gold works really well when he has
someone to bounce off of like this from
there like like you end up having them
basically jump back ten minutes before
and then we end up finding out it's not
10 minutes before the massacre in Wayne
Manor it's 10 minutes before Booster
Gold basically saved the parents of
Bruce Wayne when he was a kid and that's
kind of a tragic thing here is because
Booster Gold kind of has to make this
choice right I mean it's kind of like
look basically I just have to buy time
he's got to kill ten minutes but he's
not telling he's not telling Bruce that
Bruce has no idea where they are right
now all he knows is that they're on a
rooftop somewhere he doesn't know
exactly I mean he could kind of look
around the skyline and get a pretty good
idea of where they're located at but
like witnessed time passing suddenly you
have Booster Gold when he originally
showed up here and so you got two
boosters fighting at the same time and
so of course he shows up the intention
is to basically save the pairs of Bruce
Wayne but instead Thomas Wayne I'm sorry
Bruce responds exactly as you would
expect he takes out that version of
Booster Gold and so from there it's like
okay now we basically have to like let
this let these events unfold you end up
having like the original Booster Gold
facing off against Booster Gold as he
I'm sorry facing off against Bruce Wayne
alongside Booster Gold as he exists now
and all the while where this fights
taking place you have Thomas and Martha
who hear the gunshots of like Bruce
Wayne when he's facing off against these
two boosters and the response is well
things are kind of weird so like let's
go this way instead and they run into
Joe Chill Joe Chill that whole
circumstance unfolds exactly if you
would expect it to Thomas and Martha
Wayne are dead and this is kind of crazy
because it's basically Tom Kane's way of
saying like Bruce Wayne kind of
engineered the death of his own parents
Bruce Wayne basically this kind of has
to look down and realize that his
parents are dead that like there's no
way to escape this and so ultimately
Bruce Wayne turns a gun on himself and
and that's the end of that and so in
turn like Booster Gold basically fix
things and so of course Booster Gold
jumps back to everything steps back to
the way it was supposed to be and then
of course Bruce Wayne or I'm sorry
Booster Gold reveals everything to Bruce
and says hey look here's what I did and
here's how I screwed up and and so on
and so forth but it's kind of cool here
because this is designed to do two
things when you expect and one you don't
expect the one you expect is it
basically just kind of shows Booster
Gold despite his best intentions usually
ends up screwing things up Booster Gold
tries to do the right thing and ends up
doing all the wrong things instead but
to me and I think I don't know if this
was Tom Kings intention but to me this
clarifies the events of Flashpoint and
what dr. Manhattan did at the outset
people will look at this and they will
say okay how can Booster Gold travel
back in time and allow Bruce Wayne's
parents to survive and then travel back
in time again and allow the
dye and things go right back to the way
they were before like flashpoint showed
us if you go into the past and you screw
things up like you'll change the future
but when you go into the past and you
try to fix them the future will still be
different originally like from the from
the way it was supposed to go because
the very fact that you traveled into the
past changed how the future is gonna
turn out like you you've altered the
course of the future so you can never
make it exactly the way we were supposed
to be you've altered the direction
things are gonna go alright here's what
I think this works if you look at
flashpoint for the way it was originally
written that logic is sound the way that
you think about that is 100% correct
it is absolutely accurate but what DC we
worth has said is that when Barry Allen
went into the past and saved his mom's
life and then initiated the flashpoint
universe and then went back in time
after realizing that his mom has to die
things were supposed to go back to
normal
nothing was supposed to change but dr.
Manhattan changed it and so this fits in
perfectly with that because what it
basically says is like that can happen
someone can go into the past they can
change things realize that what they
change was wrong go back to the past
again to set them back to rights and
everything will be okay everything will
be fine
it's the fact that dr. Manhattan changed
things due to flashpoint that's what
really throws that throws a wrench in
the works
that's why everything seems so different
now than the way it was originally
supposed to be before before a new 52
happen before the events of Flashpoint
took place so I wanted to throw that out
there because to me it kinda it works I
think it works really really well I
think it actually fits in perfectly I
think that one probably one of the
reasons why Tom keen may have done it
like this is so that in future stories
when the whole DC thing gets lined out
we get that huge explanation from dr.
Manhattan about what he did why he did
it and so on and so forth and even if
things don't go back to normal this will
fit in very nicely with that it'll fit
in nice and snug with everything that's
been done so far and it won't really
stand out and it won't really you know
be out of place but without being said
guys we're gonna go and bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
commerce explain to make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you
[Music]